[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
Francia 24 Marta Moya ya está con
nosotros en el estudio Marta estamos a
mitad de semana Y empezamos hoy antes de
que nada haciendo la mención al día
internacional para el acceso a la
información sin la que no podríamos
hacer un verdadero periodismo mucho
menos estar en esta sección de revista
de prensa Marta y para entrar en materia
iniciamos entonces con la prensa local
aquí en Colombia también la
internacional sobre los últimos
movimientos del kremlin con no local en
Rusia con los con los movimientos de
kremy en cuanto a estos referendos que
el día de ayer se llevó a cabo digamos
el último no lo de la autodeterminación
de varias regiones y vamos a empezar con
el mosquite Times buenos buenos días
Raúl Así es empezamos con este periódico
independiente que titula este miércoles
la victoria prorrusa en los referendos
organizados en Ucrania abre el camino
hacia la anexión este artículo dice que
el apoyo abrumador de los resultados a
los refere entre el 87 y el 99% según
las cifras de estas regiones prorrusas
que antes ocupaban 8,8 millones de
habitantes ahora no se sabe por la
desmovilización con la guerra puede
escalar la tensión y puede bueno enviar
a estas tropas movilizadas después del
anuncio del kremlin la semana pasada
sostiene este artículo del más cute
Times que puede convertirse en una zona
de amortiguamiento los territorios y que
estos territorios Perdón se conviertan
en moneda de cambio dice que si el
kremlin sigue adelante con la anexión
Rusia reclamará la soberanía de
aproximadamente el 20% del territorio
ucraniano con crimea incluida el relleno
Austin Marta esta agencia rusa titula en
su artículo de opinión Rusia no puede
permitirse perder dice que estos
resultados de los referéndums de los
referendos Perdón nos permiten decir que
históricamente las tierras rusas han
regresado a casa sostiene Además este
artículo de opinión que Rusia no eligió
entre la paz y la guerra que Durante los
últimos siete meses desde el inicio de
la invasión rusa no el nosotros y ellos
se ha trazado con bastante Claridad y
que Ucrania que recibe armamento y
mercenarios de la otan según sostiene
este análisis Bueno pues siembra y que
occidente Perdón estará feliz con el
derramamiento de sangre en Rusia y que
no nos podemos permitir La derrota el
lujo de perder sostiene este análisis
este artículo de opinión del riano boste
de guardia ahora el de guardia nace un
explainer analizando un poco lo que
puede venir tras Esta bueno estos
referendos y dice Rusia anexará los
territorios ucranianos ocupados esta
semana sostiene que bueno analiza Cómo
podría acabar todo esto dice que bueno
los referendos muchos de las personas
que se acercaron a lo tuvieron que hacer
a punta de pistola y dice porque ha
hecho esto Putin
analistas sostienen en este explainer
del de Guardian que podría estar bueno
intentando detener la retirada de las
tropas después de la contraofensiva
ucraniana y que bueno pues estos con el
reconocimiento de los territorios se
podría amenazar con una respuesta
abrumadora incluso con La amenaza
nuclear dice este análisis que se
podrían frenar las pérdidas hasta que
las tropas rusas puedan reagruparse el
país de España Marte rápidamente para
finalizar ese tema y seguir con nuestra
revista de prensa el país está de España
en su editorial titula derrotas
domésticas de Putin dice que la
resistencia ciudadana a la movilización
parcial abre un frente al interior del
clep del kremlin tras el repliegue de
las tropas rusas la huida de decenas de
personas estos últimos días bueno
destaca estos estos crispación en la
sociedad rusa y dice que el kremlin que
pu ha conseguido la ruptura de un pacto
implícito con las clases medias que le
pidieron silencio con Ucrania y que la
guerra no les afectará la vida diaria y
esto se ha roto cambiamos ahora siete
tema Marta porque como avanzamos
nosotros empezando el programa los
derechos reproductivos sean convertido
en uno de los ejes de la campaña para
las elecciones de mitad de término en
Estados Unidos así lo refleja el final
Times Así es Raúl el financial Times
hace un análisis que titula como el
derecho al aborto está tras tocando las
elecciones de mitad de mandato sostiene
que el corte de la el fallo de la Corte
Suprema de Estados Unidos de junio ha
puesto el derecho los derechos
reproductivos en el centro de la campaña
electoral y que esto estaría energizando
a los demócratas y poniendo en algunos
apuros a los republicanos quienes
aspiran Pues a recuperar el control
tanto de la cámara de representantes
como del senado eso tiene que a raíz de
poner este tema en el centro de la
campaña
Podrían haber estrechado un poco esa
Victoria que pronosticaban todas las
toda la demoscopia Y bueno pues que este
este tema El aborto da cancha vaiden que
podría mejorar los resultados de sus
predecesores Bill Clinton y Obama en el
primer mandato en el 94 Clinton en el
2010 Obama y que el 71% de las mujeres
encuestadas sostienen que para votar el
candidato o la candidata a la que voten
tiene que compartir su posición respecto
al aborto y este es un tema principal
para las mujeres demócratas Gracias
Marta por toda la información de esta
revista de prensa mañana con más por
supuesto Gracias Raúl Hasta mañana hasta